in the last video we discovered what
seems like a problem with the Calvin
cycle that you have this big protein
here or enzyme that facilitates the
calvin cycle all of the molecules that
are involved bond to this and then it
you know twists and turns and it jams
things together so that they react
properly and we know what this is the
Rubisco Rubisco enzyme or ribulose
biphosphate carboxylase oxygenase and we
know when the Calvin cycle operates
properly you'll have some carbon dioxide
you'll have some carbon dioxide attached
on one part of this enzyme and then
you'll have some rube P or maybe you
could call it or the proper word is
ribulose one 5bi phosphate and they're
going to react and then after they react
if the everything with the calvin cycle
is going properly they're going to react
and form they're going to be jammed
together and then split in two for one
molecule of that in one molecule of that
you're going to have two molecules of
3-phosphoglycerate phospho blister rate
now in the last video I started with
three of these and three of these so I
ended up with six of these but for every
one of these you end up with two of
these this is the proper Calvin cycle
then these turn into your phospho
glyceraldehyde z' these turn into two
phosphoglyceraldehyde zorp ii gals pea
gals and then for every six that are of
these that are producing maybe I should
write a three here a three here and then
I'll have six of these and then I'll
have six of these and for every six of
these that are produced five go back
into the cycle to produce so five P gals
or glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate go back
into the cycle to per to produce the
ribulose biphosphate and one of them is
kind of our end product of
photosynthesis that can be used to
produce other carbohydrates so one P gal
and the whole problem we saw with the
calvin cycle is that Rubisco it does not
only fix carbon dioxide that instead of
carbon dioxide we can might have an
oxygen molecule we might have an oxygen
molecule that jumps in here and it can
also
- the Rubisco enzyme and in that
situation the oxygen and the ribulose
biphosphate react so if we said we had
three ribulose biphosphate sand three
oxygens instead of producing six
phosphoglycerates we're only going to
produce five five phosphoglycerates and
we're going to produce five phospho
glycolate sand you know which is that
phospho gly collate which is that
byproduct it gets processed later on so
it's this huge and then these five you
can have five here you can't have one
left over and then you're not going to
produce anything and doing this whole
cycle you have to use up a bunch of
ATP's and nadh s so this is a problem if
there's a lot of oxygen present or even
if there's just even a little bit of
oxygen present it's going to make this a
little bit less a little bit less
efficient because every now and then an
oxygen is going to jump in when you when
a carbon dioxide is needed to actually
produce an actual carbohydrate in the
end so how do plants solve this problem
well one solution would be to operate to
operate the Calvin cycle in an
environment where there is very very
little oxygen or you can almost say no
oxygen and this is exactly what some
plants doing you're like wait how do I
do that or do they have to go to a
planet where you know there's no oxygen
no what they do is and - to understand
this we'll have to understand a little
bit of of the actual makeup of the leaf
of a plant and that doesn't hurt because
everything we've been doing now has been
biochemistry it's nice to see leaves so
if I draw you know let's say that that
is a leaf that is a leaf right there can
make it look nice like a leaf that's a
nice looking leaf on your leaf surface
and actually on both sides of it you
have these little pores these little
holes these little holes on the leaf
surface they're actually surrounded by
these things called guard cells but the
important thing is that these little
pores and they're actually much smaller
than that you would have to get a
microscope to actually see them they're
called stomata or one individual of
these pores or holes are called is
called a stoma and this is where the
oxygen and the carbon or mainly the
carbon dioxide but this is where the air
enters the cell and this is actually
where water vapor is also released from
the cells
draw cross section of a leaf so if we
draw a cross section so let me do my
best to draw a cross section like this
let me draw it like that and maybe
that's the bottom of the leaf this would
be my stoma this is the actual opening
this is the actual opening and plants
can actually open and close their stoma
and we'll talk a little or their stomata
I shouldn't say stoma is the plural of
stoma is stomata they can open and close
their stomata but the important thing to
realize is what's going on inside the
cell so most plants you have this whole
photosynthetic process or photosynthesis
process occurring in these mesophyll
cells which are really just these middle
layer cells and I'll do a detailed video
in the future about the anatomy of a
plant but these are the mesophyll cells
this is where photosynthesis normally
occurs mezzo fill and because they use
carbon dioxide or they need air there's
actually actually at Druid one let me
draw a little bit better there's
actually space between them so that air
can get to them so there's mezzo fill in
as well phil i'm doing a very rough
drawing but in this situation air can
enter through a stoma and then it can
fill these the the space between these
mesophyll cells and it can provide air
to the mesophyll cells and when I say
air that air is made up of carbon
dioxide and oxygen and nitrogen all the
things that are in our air and of course
it needs the carbon dioxide to actually
perform the Calvin cycle
now we just said that you know it's not
just getting co2 if it was just getting
co2 you wouldn't worry about
photorespiration it's also getting
oxygen it's also getting molecular
oxygen so what can the plant do to
prevent this and not all plant you know
most plants just deal with
photorespiration it's just a little less
efficient than the ideal but some plants
have I guess we could say evolved past
the photo respiration problem and these
are called c4 plants or another or C or
they perform c4 photosynthesis
photosynthesis and we'll understand
hopefully in a few minutes why it's
called c4 and just as a reminder when we
go up to the mechanism up here
classic Calvin cycle the FIR
is to buy product is this
phosphoglycerate this is a three carbon
chain so it's saying that the the first
time that you fix carbon dioxide or
actually the first time you fix carbon
dioxide or oxygen but let's say the
first time you fix carbon dioxide you
end up with a three carbon chain
molecule that's why this is called c3
photosynthesis so that's a clue on c4
plants the very first time that they fix
carbon dioxide they must end up with a
four carbon molecule and what they do
and this is the interesting thing is you
have all your mesophyll you have all
your mesophyll cells that are out here
they're getting air they're getting
carbon dioxide you know they're getting
carbon dioxide and they're getting
oxygen and whatever else so you have all
your mesophyll cells they're getting air
but you also have cells that are deeper
within more embedded within the leaf
that aren't being exposed directly to
the air coming through the stomata so
you have these bundle sheet cells and
these are actually the cells that
surround you know the actual the actual
pipes in the plant that that distribute
the fluid up and down the plant and
we'll do a whole video on the anatomy of
the plant I really just want you to
understand what's going on in c4
photosynthesis so you have these other
cells that are more embedded there they
don't have direct access to the air so
these are bundle sheath cells bundle
sheath and what these plants do is the
carbon dioxide comes in - so in the
standard calvin cycle
everything happens in the mesophyll
cells and you have to deal with
photorespiration in your c4 plants or
your plants performing c4 photosynthesis
what happens is is the carbon dioxide
comes in so this is in the mesophyll
cell let me be neat about it so in our
mesophyll and our mesophyll cell
mesophyll that's that right there you
have co2 coming in and it reacts instead
of reacting with Rupiah ribulose
biphosphate it reacts with another very
hairy sounding compound we'll just call
it
pep but it's phosphine all pyruvate
so--that's pep and just you just have to
remember it is a three carbon it is a
three carbon chain now let me write down
the word just because sometimes you
might want to know what does what does
pep stand for its Foss phenol phenol
pyruvate or phosphine all pyruvic acid
either way pyruvate three carbon
molecule it's got other stuff hanging
off of this but we just have to remember
the carbons so when these two react what
are you going to end up with well you
could guess you're going to end up you
have one carbon you have three carbons
you're going to end up with a four
carbon molecule you're going to end up
with a four carbon molecule and this
this reaction right here is facilitated
not by Rubisco ribulose biphosphate
oxygen carboxylase oxygenase all it's
facilitated by a different enzyme and
this is the key this is the key for C
this so this is a different enzyme this
is called pep carboxylase let me write
it down pep-pep carboxylase and that's a
fitting name remember right Rubisco or
ribulose biphosphate carboxylase it
reacted ribulose biphosphate with carbon
now or oxygen that's where that oxygen
is comes from but now we have something
that reacts tap our phosphine all
pyruvate with carbon dioxide so it's
called pep carboxylase actually this is
carboxylase not carboxylate carboxylase
it's an enzyme
this is pep carboxylase and what's
special about pep carboxylase and why
it's useful in preventing
photorespiration
is that it can only fix carbon it can
only fix carbon not not oxygen so you
can imagine this is occurring in the
mesophyll cell you have oxygen and
carbon dioxide running around here but
only only carbon dioxide can react with
the pep via the pep carboxylase so then
you they react they perfect they
actually produce a solo acetic acid or
excel acid
eight Solow let me write that
oxaloacetate and you might remember this
from the krebs cycle this was what this
was the thing that was the first
reactive species in our Krebs cycle so
all of these molecules you know they're
there are they keep showing up in our in
our chemical pathways and that's
interesting if you find that type of
thing interesting but the important
thing is they felt form oxaloacetate
then oxaloacetate gets converted
converted let me make it I made this not
as neatly as I would like to but then
that gets converted to either malate or
aspartate but these are all four carbon
molecules they're a little different
they're going to have different oxygens
and hydrogen's hanging off of them but
this is either malate or or aspartate
did I just say carboxylase no there's
going to form either malate or aspartate
most books will just say Oh a little
it'll eventually just form into malate
only and then this this malate will then
essentially react to produce carbon
dioxide you're like wait with that that
that doesn't make sense I have carbon
dioxide it gets fixed in oxaloacetic
acid and then it gets turned into malate
or aspartate and then later i'm going to
turn into carbon dioxide again what's
the whole point and this is the key this
is this is this is the whole crux of the
issue so now this malate is going to be
converted back into pep and carbon
dioxide you're like what was the whole
point of this whole reaction I just
ended up with carbon dioxide and pep
again I'm just going in circles but the
neat thing about this and the reason why
this prevents photorespiration
is that this part this part of the
reaction right here maybe I should do it
like this this part of the reaction
occurs in the mesophyll cell it occurs
up here it occurs over here in the
mesophyll cell so you have this malate
and then the malate actually gets
transferred into these bundle sheath
cells so the malate gets transferred
into
bundle sheath cells via little tubes
that connect the cells called
plasmodesmata sounds like the name of
our horror movie so let me draw this let
me draw this a little bit neater so over
here you have with exposure to the air
with exposure there you have your
mesophyll cell right air is coming in O
to co2 everything is coming in but only
co2 can be fixed with pep so you have
the pep here the phosphine old pyruvate
so you have your pep here pep only co2
can be reacted with pep because of the
pep carboxylase the pep carboxylase this
is the enzyme that's operating so this
is much more specific than the ribulose
biphosphate carboxylase or the Rubisco
so pep carboxylase so the oxygen just
gets ignored even though it's hanging
around these metal fuel cells and then
these this gets converted oxaloacetic
acid and then to malate but once it gets
converted to malate the malate gets
transferred deeper into deeper into the
actual cell via these plasmodesmata so
this might be budding right up against
right up against a bundle sheet cell
that's deeper in the cell this bundle
sheet cell has no access to oxygen right
so the malate comes in you have these
little pipes that connect the cell maybe
I'll just draw one pipe actually so
let's say there's one pipe so the malate
can come here and then within this
deeper cell within this bundle sheath
cell bundle sheath it can then react to
form carbon dioxide and pyruvate and
then the pyruvate so let's say then this
is the pyruvate and with that pyruvate
can then later go back to actually form
the pep again so this can go back
through your plasmodesmata and form the
pep so the whole value here is now in
the bundle sheet cell I have an
environment that only has
carbon dioxide I have no oxygen here I
was able to essentially select for the
carbon dioxide outside or closer to the
air in the mesophyll cell and now that
I'm deeper within the within the plant
I'm in an environment that only has co2
because I've already selected for it and
now I can perform the Calvin cycle so
now inside this deeper cell inside this
bundle sheet cell I can fix the carbon
dioxide with the ribulose biphosphate
using Rubisco just like we learned in
the original calvin cycle and we have
the whole cycle and we produce our
sugars we produce our
phosphoglyceraldehyde x' or you know pee
gals whatever you want to call them and
the whole value of this is that we were
able to avoid the photorespiration
problem because now the Calvin cycle is
occurring an environment that only has
carbon dioxide and I think I already
mentioned it but this is called c4
photosynthesis c4 photosynthesis and
it's an adaption to essentially make
sure that you don't waste waste cycles
of your calvin cycle by photo through
photorespiration of course it was called
c4 because the first time that carbon
gets fixed it doesn't happen in the
calvin cycle it happens up here with pep
carboxylase and it gets fixed with pep
into a 4 carbon chain and that's why
it's called c4 photosynthesis